there's nine really subtle Financial
myths or financial lies that are super
hard to detect like it takes money to
make money or you're in it for the long
haul or you know there's so many memes
or kind of philosophies or myths that so
many people still adopt because they
just don't know any better if I have the
right work ethic or I work hard enough
I'll be better off hard work with the
wrong philosophy still equals bankruptcy
that thinks they have a money problem
that's just a symptom that's a symptom
of the problem money is the receipt it's
on the other side of the equation it's a
byproduct what drives money is we have
to understand what is it we can provide
that's valuable to others that we're
capable of doing cuz I know people that
preach the word passion all the time and
the problem is Passion alone can lead to
bitterness passion can lead you astray
or even make you broke it's kind of like
putting fuel in the wrong place without
a tank and then everything bursts into
flames and it crashes that happens if
people are in a hobby that they're
passionate about thinking it's a
business the toughest part and the Crux
of society comes down to this thing
right here money field is an exclusive
video series where self-made
millionaires share their secrets on how
they got rich in this episode you'll
learn how to invest your hard-earned
dollars what is the right amount you
need to retire and how to fix your
limied beliefs around money these are
the lessons that they don't teach you in
school about making money and we
partnered with the series Creator Jeff
Hayes to bring it to you on my YouTube
channel
enjoy welcome to episode two of money
revealed we've got a great lineup for
you today momentum is building
excitement is building and I want you to
remember you should share this with
other people this free viewing is up
right now share it with other people
that you think can benefit from this
information and let's just Dive Right
into episode
[Music]
two when I think of our next guest I
think of the term Maverick Garett
Gunderson is a maverick in the financial
industry he wrote a book called killing
sacred cows and let me tell you he's got
some really strong opinions that are at
variance with conventional thinking when
it comes to your finances and how to
invest your finances and how to create a
better future for yourself his energy is
inescapable his Brilliance will shine
you're going to love this content it has
had a major impact on my life and now
I'm excited because it's going to have a
major impact on yours enjoy my interview
with Garrett Gunderson Garrett thanks so
much for taking some time out of your
day to be with us give us a little
background on you grew up in a small
coal mining town started my first
business when I was 15 years old nothing
too Innovative just detailing cars named
it Garrett gunderson's Car Care my dad
being a coal miner and my mom working in
a credit union uh I started detailing
the repossessed vehicles I started
cleaning the surface vehicles for the
mine and uh then I went out and did a
business competition with only $600 in
net income in the business I made $500
for being the rural young entrepreneur
of the year and uh got pretty fascinated
by just conveying messages and teaching
since it was really hard to kind of
scrub bugs and tar and buff cars but uh
yeah then I ended up winning $5,000 for
being a young entrepreneur of the year
for the state of Utah and unlike most
teenagers I actually decided I want to
invest that money you know I want to get
out the the small little town of price
and hit the big city of Salt Lake City
you know the thriving Financial Metropol
and uh so I went on a path trying to
figure out how to invest that money
first time I invested complete mistake
18 years old cuz before I was 18 my mom
is an Italian wasn't willing to sign off
as a custodian their money management
method was folders coffee cans put cash
in that thing and put it in the seller
right and just forget about it which for
a lot of people that's probably a better
money management method than what I've
seen but for me I wanted to do something
bigger and so when I was 18 I finally
made my first investment they promised
me 18% return returns and if I just put
a mere $70 a month away I was going to
be a multi-millionaire 40 years from
then and uh took an econometrics course
in college and figured out there was no
chance that was going to happen and uh
in figuring that out started asking more
questions and ironically in asking the
questions got led to being into the
financial industry when I was 19 years
old which may sound really cool but I
was just a product pedler I sold life
insurance I sold mutual funds and my job
was to bring warm bodies into the firm
so they could sell them something while
I sat there and so-called learned but
that got me my start so you say you were
a product peder um yeah but that's kind
of masquerades as a uh I said I was a
financial planner I said that I was too
embarrassed to admit I was a life
insurance salesman at the time my tie
wasn't short enough my belly wasn't big
enough in my mind I mean I wanted to
sound really cool and the first two
years was 98 and 99 I was a genius I was
a financial Einstein in my community cuz
they're Cashing Out double e bonds and
putting in mutual funds and everybody
made money in those two years and so
they're like wow this is great until
2000 came around and that started to
change and that's when I began to ask
questions and that's where I got rid of
kind of these cliches that indoctrinated
my mind like it takes money to make
money or you're in it for the long haul
or the Market's on sale now is a good
time to buy well it was a bad time to
buy when most people bought you know
there's so many memes or kind of
philosophies or myths that so many
people still adopt because they just
don't know any better it's just what
they're trained taught and educated to
do and it's questioned even though
there's been a massive failure rate and
we've watched this great financial
experiment absolutely be decimated yet
people are still taking part in the
experiment of buying and holding setting
money aside hoping that it works out
budgeting to the point where they stop
producing value because they're in a
restrictive mindset buying into scarcity
thinking that anyone that's wealthy has
done something wrong I mean there's so
many misnomers that lead people astray
and I think it comes from perspective
first because our perspective determines
our action and if people are in a
perspective of scarcity that there's not
enough and look let's face it there's
times where when you look at people's
environment where they're born they're
born in a third world country they're
just trying to struggle to get food
they're trying to deal with crazy
diseases like maybe ringworm or issues
that are coming up man that's all
they're trying to do is survive but
there's other people that aren't under
that same survival circumstance but
their mentality doesn't change and
because they're in Survival it becomes a
selfish state of existence that selfish
state of existence is what can I do for
me neglecting the thought of what can I
do for others and because of that they
stay stuck they stay poor or maybe
middle class at best with Herculean
effort to say if I have the right work
ethic or I work hard enough I'll be
better off hard work with the wrong
philosophy still equals bankruptcy So
based on what you're saying and you know
kind of as you're portraying all this do
we have especially in North America
right now do we have a a crisis as far
as people moving toward retirement
oh retirement first of all it's time to
redefine it MH if we think about
retirement it means to take out of
service and the notion came up from the
Industrial Age where people were working
tirelessly they're dying early because
they've worked themselves to death
literally and now we're thinking oh
let's retire and retirement age 65 and
now people are living 30 years past 65
instead of dying at age 60 and now
they're supposed to live off their
investment and Social Security and other
programs like that while they still have
the ability to produce they're not
producing anymore and they actually
start to tax society and even worse the
number one fear of a
retiree is their fear of running out of
money according to USA Today right so
think about this there's this dream sold
to them one day someday you can finally
go on these trips you can finally live
the life you've always dreamed of you
could spend time with family you know
let's dream big about it and the
planners get them thinking about that
then they're told yeah just set your
money aside scrimp pinch pennies how to
get blisters on your fingers not knowing
that no one shrinks their way to wealth
but they just hand the money over to
people they've never met because even
the fund manager is more a different
person than the product Peddler right
with stocks that they don't even know
what those stocks are what's happening
in those boardrooms the fees that are
coming out of that why they would make
money why they would lose money they
just kind of go through that process in
hopes that one day it's going to work
out yet 98% of them when they turn 65
they're not economically independent
meaning if they stop working they don't
have enough income coming in from all of
their Investments and Social Security or
whatever programs are out there to cover
their basic expenses so now what do they
do especially if they were looking
forward to stopping at age 65 they
stopped building skills they stopped
moving forward in growing way they
thought maybe College was their only way
to grow and then afterwards it's just
get a job and work hard and then one day
you'll have a pension that takes care of
you we've watched pensions collapse
partially because they were supposed to
earn 8% % a year because we've been
taught that the stock market's going to
earn 8% a year since the year 2000 BC
but the reality is it hasn't done that
and when it doesn't do that just 1%
makes an exponential difference and all
of a sudden they thought they were
heading to one destination they're not
even close to that but at the same time
they're ill equipped ill-prepared and
unfortunately they haven't been trained
and how to produce more cash flow how to
expand their means to be more productive
they're not thinking in the world of
value creation if they're in the
retirement mindset they're thinking in
the in the thought process of
preservation when they get there and all
that it was supposed to be it's not but
now they're in a scary world and it you
know it's it's a really difficult time
because it's taxing the system so here's
kind of the ultimate irony here it seems
like a huge contradiction the big
unknown is when am I going to die right
nobody knows that I mean and that that's
kind of like you're trying to calibrate
to this unknown which is a major
variable in this equation completely so
I'm I'm hearing what you're saying now
and I'm starting to add it up in my own
mind wait a minute I'm going to retire
at a certain age and then I want to have
a certain lifestyle beyond that
retirement to last me the rest of my
life but we don't know what the rest of
your life is so how do you calibrate to
that so so suddenly there's people who
are trying to act morally meaning um hey
I'm doing the right thing I'm putting
away the money as I'm told to do I'm
putting it into places yeah I'm I'm
actually one of these people who
actually isn't being a Mindless you know
consumer that just you know throws
caution to the wind I'm putting the
structure in place I'm delaying
gratification because I'm going to do
the right thing but it's all based on a
pack of Lies this is the contradiction
at the heart of the matter everyone's
hearing about this term this phrase
Financial Freedom right what is
Financial Freedom my definition of
Financial Freedom is when money is not
the primary reason or excuse why we do
or don't do something it's still
consideration but not the primary
consideration when when it's someone's
primary consideration they destroy all
opportunity they go you say hey would
you like to do this I can't afford it
that's the Mantra I don't have the time
I can't afford it they're almost kind of
cousins but there's no freedom in that
and yet we think that if there's a
certain amount of money in a bank
account that that's going to create
Freedom that doesn't create freedom
because there's people with a lot of
money that are just afraid that they're
going to lose that money or we've seen a
situation unprecedented over the last
couple decades interest rates have been
so low that retirees are not generating
the income that they expected so great
if you're in business right now you're
borrowing money rates have been great
you know that's awesome for you not such
good news for the people that need to
create that income because they haven't
really been trained in how to produce
cash flow they went their entire life
just accumulating net worth and net
worth is relatively worthless if it
can't be converted to cash so here's the
contradiction Financial Freedom is Prof
that's what's being professed that's
what being taught but let's examine the
reality of that M it's actually
Financial bondage because we hand our
money over we wait we get there and now
our entire future is in the hands of a
market that we don't control people that
are managing it that we don't know how
they manage it who's even managing it
what the fees are that are coming out
what's going to happen because that
dictates our income and these are the
three things that enslave retirees
number one is interest rates we've
already talked about that they remain
low your income remains low number two
taxes we have a $20 trillion debt in the
United States how are we going to pay
for that one way might be taxes if taxes
go up when you're on a fixed income your
net income goes down that means you have
to start cutting things out of your life
I've met people that were
multi-millionaires on paper million
dollar paid off home million and a half
in their retirement they're eating two
Mills a day and not because they're
intermittent fasting simply because
they're afraid if they spend too much in
all these trips they had planned no
they're cutting that back they're
cutting that out all these relationships
they were going to go cultivate and
spend time with you know what when
they're not in control of their money
and when all of a sudden that money
starts to infringe upon their
relationships because they don't choose
to do things in the name of saving money
and most importantly they've lost
purpose I think other than poor health
there's nothing that will help someone
die faster than losing control of those
three things and the third thing why
they're in financial bondage is
inflation inflation has continued to
exist if we went back to the 1980s we
interviewed everyone hey what's a good
amount of money to have a retirement
plan we might hear a quarter of a
million dollars from most people maybe
half a million dollars for people that
were really kind of out there and those
people that were really Forward Thinking
might say a million dollars yet today
that's not going to get you economically
independent a million dollars will
produce less in today's interest rate
environment than the lower end of income
earners so now of the sudden you're a
Millionaire on paper but living like a
popper that's Financial bondage
Financial Freedom comes from a
completely different place so this seems
to all boil down to the philosophy of
money right what's your view of reality
relative to money why do you think that
and then what should you do right those
are the three foundational philosophical
questions it has to go all the way back
to what we learn in childhood from our
mothers fathers teachers preachers Etc
so you've have such context on this
because you've made it the study of your
life how do you see
so money is a tool and it was it was
invented as an efficient way to exchange
but with that efficiency came complexity
for people because there are times where
people are given something for nothing
uh slot machines or just enough of a
reward or a story of someone that bought
a stock and made it big so we have to go
to the foundational premise to begin and
that foundational piece is that there's
two factions one faction is people
believe there's a finite amount of money
so if anyone has more money that's less
for me MH okay but here's the Paradox
and let's go to the other side even if
there were finite amount of money which
they're printing it as you watch this
but even if there were a finite amount
of money there's an infinite number of
times that money can exchange hands and
exchange hands because of goods services
or experience and if I said that more
simply it's really a matter of value
creation value creation is the engine
for exchange M when we stop creating
value for one another let me get even
more raw than this there's a Divinity to
diversity meaning that we all have
different abilities skills preferences
talents if we all could do all the same
things we wouldn't even exchange with
one another but wealth is actually built
through unequal exchange so for example
I wrote a book right and if I were to
sell you that book for $20 you would
only give me that $20 if you felt like
the book was worth more more than
$20 I would only sell you that book if I
felt like the book was worth less than
$20 for me so we actually could both
walk away from that exchange wealthier
but most people don't believe that you
could end up wealthier through exchange
they think that it's a win lose Zero Sum
game so it's a competitive nature it's a
jealous nature that's where scarcity
becomes the rule and entitlement becomes
the Crux of society feeling entitled to
something else or feeling jealous so
instead of driving from what can I do to
serve others what can I do to solve
problems and by the way the bigger the
problem the bigger the payoff and if
someone in scarcity sees a problem they
usually complain about it they point it
out they talk about why it's going to
ruin their lives or other people's lives
and they get caught up in this really
complicated place called the external
economy the external economy one thought
isn't going to solve that entire thing
one motion isn't going to solve the
entire economy but what I like like to
look at instead is our personal economy
we'll have our own personal economy our
own network our own relationships our
own ideas and our own actions that we
have control over on a day-to-day basis
so if instead of getting caught up in
the overwhelming nature of everything
that's going wrong in the world and
complaining about it we picked one area
that we saw more clearly than everyone
else that we had a lesson or an ability
to solve that structure or that issue
and we were willing to exchange with
other people that were fantastic in that
if all of a sudden we started to focus
there instead of just pointing out the
problem coming up with the solution for
the problem there would be more wealth
that's created because there would be
more exchange that's facilitated so
think of it this way exchange creates
wealth the more we exchange with one
another the more wealth it's created and
a dollar doesn't end because I spend it
you take that dollar then you get to use
that dollar again and then someone else
uses the dollar the more times that
exchange is hands the more what we call
in economy velocity happens so quick
economics lesson without you know
getting complicated or putting anyone to
sleep it's just gross domestic product
that's the output of a country divided
by its money supply equals its velocity
so if we want to increase velocity it's
simply with the same amount of dollars
how can we get that to circulate more
often amongst each other because we're
creating value for one another doing
things that someone else isn't good at
I'm not good at organizing my garage I
found someone that loves it they're
passionate about it they actually always
work extra time there because like oh I
got a couple more things I want to work
on they love it I I once when I when I
got a review in the New York Post they
were saying you know gunderson's book
talks about people doing things that
they enjoy but there's plenty of work
that no one enjoys and we see programs
like dirty jobs and all this kind of
stuff and I kind of thought about that
for a minute and then I met a guy from
briam City Utah who ran a sewage
treatment plant and it was the he loved
it he was lit up by it so there are sick
enough people to you know love the
things that we hate and I think this is
how we redefine retirement we retire
from the things that we hate and embrace
the things that we're very best at and
rather than thinking it takes money to
make money and use that as a defeating
declaration like I don't have money I'm
never going to make money it doesn't
take money to make money it takes value
it takes two other forms of capital
mental Capital which is our ideas our
knowledge our wisdom it's systems it's
tools it's our unique insights times
relationship Capital people networks
organizations mentors family friends and
all we're doing business is just the
bridge between those two things our
mental capital or ideas to relationship
Capital so how can our ideas impact
someone's life for the positive so
anyone that thinks they have a money
problem that's just a symptom that's a
symptom of the problem money is the
receipt it's on the other side of the
equation it's a byproduct what drives
money is mental and relationship Capital
so your one idea or one relationship
away from the next dollar that you make
or the next level of prosperity that you
can have and if we could focus on that
what do we bring to the world versus
what does the world owe us what can we
do to contribute right now even if we
have no dollars in our pocket I mean I
started my very first job that I ever
had was a dump site where they were
doing a grand opening it was 105 degrees
and we had to drive these These nails
into a tent that was in rock that took
us forever with sledgehammers but it got
me some money before that I I remember
pulling weeds from Mrs aletto I got paid
I think $2 for the entire day but it
just taught me I want to do something
different what else can I do that's
better and I really realized that in the
old days we were paid for our braa MH
maybe or for being part of the lucky
sperm club and you were born into
royalty and sure there was a lot more of
that back then than there is now but
I've met kids that aren't even teenagers
yet that are worth a million dollars not
because they inherited money not because
they came from money but because of the
Advent of the internet I met someone
recently that he hosts and puts on these
huge conventions for Minecraft and Lego
that started because his daughter wanted
to film YouTube videos one of our mutual
friends his son had a $590,000 revenue
at 16 years old starting a business with
less than
$1,000 the problem is most people don't
even know that this is a possibility
they don't recognize this exist because
they're confused about money and they
wake up with the wrong question in their
mind how can I make more money how can I
make more money make tend to move you
towards some level of action but a more
powerful question would be what issues
are there in the world that I could
solve what actions can I take to
contribute what ways do I feel engaged
and compelled to do something and
sometimes you do that without Financial
reward you just contribute to someone
because as you become a contributor and
you're thinking about value creation you
leave scarcity and embrace abundance in
something I call the producer Paradigm
where you find seek to create more value
in the world than you take from it
people that are poor they're in Survival
so they're not necessarily thinking
about contributing more to the world
than they take they're thinking about
just making it another day that's a
mindset people stay in the survival
mindset that don't even have to stay
there and they unfortunately get stuck
in the consumer condition where they
look to extract more from the world than
they give and that is never an equation
for wealth or exchange and it's why they
start to have Envy frustration anger and
spend more time complaining than doing
so it sounds very much like the
entrepreneurial disposition um about
saying hey let me figure out a way to
add value and and create income to
myself as a result of adding value now
let's maybe look at the person who has a
job right decent job but it's steady
paycheck based on you know fixed amount
of uh working hours that they do that
can be characterized maybe as a career
for a lot of people how should they be
thinking about this as an entrepreneur
what's an entrepreneur an entrepreneur
is someone that works inside of an
organization but what they do is they
abandon this time and effort Industrial
Age economy where you just punch a clock
you show up and you trade time for
dollars and instead they start
considering how they contribute to the
bottom line of the organization and
rather than being an owner because
ownership a lot of times means hey if
you're sued now you're involved in that
lawsuit hey if you need to add a capital
call because they're short on cap that
month you got to infuse cash if all of a
sudden things are tight you're not
taking a paycheck there's not a lot of
people that have kind of the desire to
do that and so they can be
entrepreneurial where they say I'd like
to have more upside potential if I can
contribute more to this firm if I can
contribute and understand how I direct
and improve the bottom line I'd like to
have a little piece of that so now
they're part of a community they're part
of a culture they're part of an
organization where they could Thrive see
some people that are more engineering
minded and methodical don't love
starting a business because they think
of all the number of things that most
business owners we have enough I you
know ignorance and arrogance to just
plow through and then we deal with it
when it comes up they're pretty smart to
see that ahead of time a lot of times
they can Thrive within an organization
um and I really feel like we're in this
economy right now where it doesn't take
massive amounts of money to start a
business there's so many people that
have side hustles right I mean I have
people I know that they rented out two
rooms in their house through Airbnb and
that started cash flowing and they
bought their first real EST property
that was for a rental I know other
people that said hey I have good
artistic you know quality so I'm going
to go and put my services on different
online platforms and all of a sudden
they're getting clients and they they do
that work graphic work at night right so
there's so many things and platforms
that great entrepreneurs have brought to
us that an entrepreneur or someone that
doesn't have the stomach to just take
all that responsibility on themselves
can now participate in to increase their
income because all the financial books
in the world try to get you to save s
sacrifice delay defer budget and that
just takes extraordinary amounts of
discipline and energy and if we're in
shrinking based thinking that's about
restriction instead of production that
is a harmful place to be instead I'd
like people to think about how they can
expand their means because we've all
hard to live within our means which
usually thinks oh let's have life suck
let's cut out good things that we enjoy
and you know what after meeting you I
just enjoy Finer Things in life uh my
dad showed me boxed wine when I was
young you showed me bottled wine and not
only just any bottles you know and then
you showed me dark chocolate my I grew
up on milk chocolate all of a sudden
those things a luxury once enjoyed
becomes a necessity but the key is yes
it's important to live with in your
means but continually seek to expand
your means because if I'm telling you to
pinch pennies to save 10% of your income
and then try to get through Herculean
efforts once again 10% return which is
really hard to get for the majority of
people in today's world that don't own a
business that's 10% of 10% but if
instead we figured out what are your
best qualities what are the things and
skills and abilities you have that you
could cultivate and grow and then you
invest back into yourself it doesn't
show up on a piece of paper initially
and that's the tough thing when I put
money in an investment like a mutual
fund or a savings account or a
certificate of deposit I get a statement
when I invest into my own skills my own
abilities I'm now relying more on myself
which can be a scary thing but at the
same time it's going to take a a little
bit longer to pay off but if it does
imagine if I increase my income by 25%
that's 25% of 100% expanding our means
is so critical and as soon as we forget
to do that or we start shrinking because
retirement's around the corner or we
stop thinking about enhancing our skills
we are in a disruptive time and place
before you could have the same skill for
20 30 years now there's people that
maybe learn to drive but now there's
driverless vehicles coming out they're
going to have to have a new set of
skills and this is the toughest part the
toughest part and the Crux of society
comes down to this thing right
here that if we are dependent upon an
income and that is what's going to put
food on the table or take care of our
family it is super difficult to make
decisions that are the right decisions
in the long term due to that scarce
filling in the short term as a matter of
fact to go deeper in this this is why
great and even good people do bad things
because they're so concerned about their
family which is Noble but at the same
time they don't see the the outcomes and
what they're creating in the world that
could be destructive and they don't want
to question it because it could
jeopardize the very nature of their
income what I want to see is people
liberated where they create economic
independence as their foundational piece
get there in 3 years or seven years not
wait for 30 years have enough cash flow
coming in that they have choice they
have options they have an inkling of
what that freedom feels like and now
they can make more powerful choices
swing for the fence in what they're up
to choose not to do something if it's
not ethical or moral for themselves or
if they see something that excites them
they have a permission slip to go for it
you wrote a New York Times bestselling
book Killing sacred cows and it created
quite a stir quite a controversy what's
the theme of the book that there's nine
really subtle Financial myths or
financial lies that are super hard to
detect the reason they're difficult to
detect is because we look through the
lens of the myth we look through the
lens of the lie and there's a lot of
marketing to support that so if we
continue to follow these things the
first one is the myth of the finite pie
there's only so much to go around and if
someone else has something there's less
for us and we can go hundreds of years
back and Thomas Malthus would say we're
going to run out of food we're going to
run out of land but he didn't consider
Innovation he didn't consider other
factors that came up and so that's the
first chapter but there's things in
there like you know un it for the long
haul or it takes money to make money or
a penny saved is a penny earned that are
so common that they're memes within
society that just go unquestioned
beliefs that we go oh yeah you just are
supposed to save early you're supposed
to save often you're supposed to save
regardless of what happens and in the
long haul it all be okay and we get
convinced of that and if we follow it it
starts to slowly Rob and confiscate our
well-being our financial lives and most
importantly it has people abdicate
responsibility which leaves them in a
dangerous place financially and so that
book helps them to detect understand and
avoid the subtle lies that are hard to
see because obvious lies pretty easy for
us to avoid I said oh I'm I live on Mars
I just live on Mars we just laugh right
but if on the other hand I'm like no the
market is goes up and down and it's
averaged
10% but then we just look where's that a
subtle lie well let's look at averages
for a minute if I had 100 Grand and it
loses 10% we know that becomes 90 grand
but the next year if it gains 10% and we
turn on the news they're like good news
the markets rallied we're back up we've
recovered we didn't recover the time
that was lost that's the first subtle
lie the second is if we earned 10% on 90
grand we're only at 99 Grand if there
were no fees right right and those fees
come out whether you make money or not
so our average return was Zero but our
actual return was negative and this is a
subtle lie that most people don't
recognize here's another subtle lie
using the same analogy if you have your
money in a Index Fund like the S&P 500
and one of these companies in the S&P
500 gets disrupted by a new technology
and it goes out of business you lost
that money on that portion forever more
they're just going to plug another
company in the S&P 500 and tell you the
average is what the new 500 companies
did not the companies you had at the
time you were invested another subtle
lie that has a big impact because you go
oh well that's a minor well this is how
minor it isn't it's pretty major if I
have money and I'm investing and I can
earn this great rate of return if I can
get that 10% I have 100 Grand over 30
years it grows to $1.74 million that's
awesome but if you have a 0.85% fee so
less than 1% it doesn't grow to 1.74
million it grows to 1.4 million that's a
$340,000 difference for less than 1%
because it's exponential it's
logarithmic and when we think in
percentages it doesn't mean dollar for
dollar because of the compounding effect
so these are the types of things that
end up where people are disappointed at
retirement they're not as far as long as
they thought and they follow this kind
of equation like the old belief of
wealth the Industrial Age belief that is
still kind of the financial experiment
that's still harming people is that
wealth is a function of three things how
much money you're willing to put away so
that's the it takes money to make money
what kind of return you can get and I'm
sure everyone's heard high risk equals
High return that's so funny the people
telling us high risk equals High return
are taking no risk because they're
making money on our money whether we
make it or not as a matter of fact look
at the industry Giants that lost almost
everything in the government bailed them
out how does the government bail them
out our tax dollars it was our money
that was lost and guess what some of
them still got their pensions or still
got their their parachutes are still got
there bonuses even though they didn't
perform this is where money becomes
confusing where people start thinking
about I get mine regardless of what
happens to anyone else that is a cloudy
level of thinking so you know when we
when we start to examine this just a
little bit closer there's huge impact on
just a few minor things so I one time
went uh to ABC Studios in New York City
and you were being interviewed on a a
new show on money yeah at ABC and they
wanted to dig into the uh the 401K issue
right which I think is a part of your
book right so uh so talk about your
perceptions of 401k because it is a
sacred cow I mean that is the vehicle
that supposed to you know for the
working person that's getting paycheck
to paycheck to paycheck they're putting
Pieces away over time and that's how
they're supposed to be accumulating for
retirement and of course it's celebrated
it's it's promoted by employers Etc and
you come in and in your book you say
it's a horrible idea yeah I I put on the
cover 401K hoax yes not just any
horrible idea I just went after it and
by the way when I first did that and
hired a PR firm they were having a hard
time booking me on anything because it
was at a time that 401ks were still
heral is the great great retirement plan
but you know what retirement plans
actually slow down the process of
achieving economic independence or what
some people might call retirement now
it's maybe faster than doing nothing but
it's slower than focusing on cash flow
and part of the reason I said 401ks were
problematic and and by the way that was
the 11th time I was on that program the
first time I was on it was during a
recession so what was the reaction of
the host in this first show oh yeah when
I said uh stop funding the 401K these
were her exact words we usually don't
get that kind of advice around here and
I said right that's why you have me on
as a guest we're going to get somewhere
today and then I said instead of funding
that they should do two other things
because this was a business program I
said they should give their best
employee arrays because what will that
say to someone during a recession and
this is in a recession in a recession
and they said well how would they do
that I said remember they're not funding
their retirement plan they're going to
fund their most important asset because
the only Assets in this world are people
everything else is stuff to serve people
so let's let's go directly to the source
and then I said the second thing is they
should go back to school was kind of how
I said it but what I meant was find an
area where they could really dial in one
of their major skill sets because
everyone else is going to be shrinking
and recessing because a recession means
we stop exchanging with one another
that's what a recession is we lose
consumer confidence or is what they
would call it on the news and it means
people start exchanging more slowly that
slows down velocity so the economy means
we have less output going back to the
original equation of GDP divided by
money supply equals velocity when we
slowdown exchange it means people aren't
serving each other as much and
unfortunately recession becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy right because
some people don't even know there's a
recession till they turn on the news
they're like oh my God we're in a
recession then they act recessionary
they call their family they call their
friends their conversations change and
wealth is actually built through
conversation I mean some of the people
that have built the most magnificent
things they didn't lift anything they
didn't do anything they thought with
their mind and created a vision right
vision is the rarest commodity on the
planet it's not Vision meaning some
mission statement on a wall that means
nothing right those those mission
statements say we're good with customer
service and we care about our customers
we put them first that's not a vision a
vision is putting the Mana on the moon
and returning them safely home within
the decade for me it's 1 million people
freed where they are economically
Independent by the time I hit the the
grave that's a that's a vision and if we
spend time focused on our vision that
creates the context or that creates the
container in which the value that we're
going to build so some people they just
say wild and crazy things but they're
committed to it so they get other people
excited enrolled and then they like this
is like a miracle that ever came about
when I'm in New York City I'm like this
is a freaking Miracle how did this city
get built someone thought of the idea
first people that are poor though don't
even have the inkling or the vision to
or or the abundance to think about that
Vision cuz they're in Survival that's
their container just to survive so this
implies that we as we discussed there's
a philosophy of money there's a
psychology that that trails that
philosophy also because you're talking
about consumer confidence for example
right I mean why is it important that
people have to you know aren't there
isn't it just a factual black and white
thing why is it that consumer confidence
should be important but literally the
psychology of the marketplace exchange
get slowed down and so you know here's
why I'm not a big fan of 401ks or you
know rsps for the Canadians or super
anization plans in Australia like we go
through it just government qualified
plans is because it has us fund other
people's dreams and Visions before we've
even figured out the best that we have
to offer the world yet that somehow
college is when it ends or high school
or that school is only when we're in a
classroom rather than a daily learning
lab that we go through life contining to
figure out looking at the end of the day
and saying what could I have done that
would allowed me to learn more to impact
more and I just use a simple impact
equation these are my two questions how
could I have reached more people how
could I have impacted those people more
deeply that's the question I'm asking
that on a regular basis and that comes
down to collaboration that comes down to
Cooperative competition and not just
trying to put other people out of
business I mean a lot of my business
grows because I actually support the
industry rather than just building
something to myself and holding it
secret I mean I had this company early
on where I would allow Financial people
to come and Shadow me see exactly how I
was doing what I was doing because I was
in my 20s and they didn't know how are
you doing this at such a young age I'm
like God just pay me come and watch then
I put together study groups and I used
to give all the secrets I didn't hold
anything back I wasn't like I'm not
going to tell them this one thing that I
do because then I have that safe I just
told them everything and you know what
happened they would come to me and say
I've got a client I really think you
could help me out with how did you
figure this out that's awesome and then
we would talk and then in talking I
would think of more ideas and they' say
have you ever thought about doing it
this way and see scarcity has us stop
sharing our ideas in fear that someone's
going to steal it from us but we
actually Rob ourselves by not sharing
them there's one thing a data point that
you told me when we met earlier on about
401ks that literally caused me within
the week I think to liquidate mine yeah
uh pay the penalty just get out and that
was the idea that uh I'm not really
personally holding those funds yeah talk
about that so it's it's a tax code so
the government actually owns the plan
and you're the beneficiary of the plan
so it'll say FBO that's the three words
the three letters for benefit of so it's
the 401K plan for benefit of Patrick
gentempo so if they want to change the
code they want to change the rules
they're fine to do that if the
government doesn't feel like they've got
enough tax income coming in they could
add a sunry tax to that and they could
just do that with the stroke of a pen
it's not a private contract it's not
really you know it's not like private
property this is the government saying
yeah we've created this provision and
the IRS allows this but they could
change that you don't get a vote in that
you don't get a say in that so that
really concerns me to give 100% control
because I'm a business guy and for me if
someone said hey I want to be in a
partnership with you here's the rules of
the partnership you put in the
money and then I'll take a percentage
but if you want out of the partnership
early I want 10% more than our agreed
upon percentage and in the future when
we sell the company
or you go to liquidate any of this my
percentage partnership will depend upon
my economic condition not yours so the
government can say hey in 30 years the
tax rates might be 60 70% if that seems
high realize this little thing that came
out in 1913 the US Revenue Act was going
to be temporary you'd have to earn quite
a bit of money adjusted for inflation to
even get hit with the 6% or 8% tax but
eventually there was a time where we had
over a 90% top tax rate in the United
States on the marginal side
and on average it's been well over 50%
so historically at the time of this
filming we're in a historically low tax
bracket so what if we're deferring that
tax into the future and simply because
of inflation we have to have a lot more
money in the future just to live the
same lifestyle inflation actually hurts
us from a tax perspective because we
have to have more dollars but those
dollars are now taxed at a higher level
when we had have more money in the
future but someone that's a millionaire
today that's a different thing than in
1913 a millionaire in 1913 could buy 10
times 20 times more than a millionaire
today with the same dollars yeah and
what's interesting is that I have at
least for me no problem imagining that
if the government gets itself into
financial trouble which it does it's
almost unavoidable that they'll look at
such assets and say you know because
this is the this is the conversation
yeah yeah they just like oh you got more
than this amount we're just taking we
taking yeah and and and that's exactly
what what almost has to happen in a
sense to solve the problem well we have
all this 401K money here uh you know we
will add some kind of a tax in addition
tax is what they'll probably call it
people will take a haircut but everybody
will share the burden etc etc after all
the toil all the fees you paid from you
know what you're invested in in that
401k the years you put into it Etc you
finally get to the point your saying hey
I deferred my
gratification all these years didn't do
certain things for my children didn't do
certain things for my spouse or myself
but I was morally doing the right thing
to be able to uh create a future of of
Independence so other I wouldn't have to
depend on other people and then what
what happens you're at the risk or
you're at the mercy basically to say
well this is held for your benefit and
we know that in the beginning when you
signed up for it these were the terms
but hey we screwed up the last 20 or 30
years we're going to take a bigger chunk
out than what you thought we might and
here's my bigger concern yeah did you
know that the majority of 401ks now when
you're an employee you're automatically
enrolled you have to opt out you don't
have to sign to get in it's just
automatic enrollment because taking care
and look 401ks are far inferior than the
pensions were it's just that pensions
didn't make it right and this took the
burden of responsibility off the
employer but this is the big lie people
are being told this will save you tax
you put in $10,000 to this plan you'll
pay $3,000 less this year but the tax
savings isn't in your pocket no it's
stuck inside of the plan and you're at a
disadvantage because if you take that
$10,000 out the next day it's not a
$3,000 cost it's a $4,000 cost and if
you take it out 30 years from now what
if taxes had gone up it could be a
$6,000 cost and so it is not a tax
savings it is a tax deferral right and
you didn't have use of the capital in
the meantime which is the big deal and
yeah so let's say a good opportunity
comes along like this is where I get
frustrated I see people trying to do the
right things they're working hard and
then they're setting money aside and
then they confide in me with their
finances and when I talk to them I see
these really high interest rate loans
and I'm like well what did your 401k do
in the last few years and the 401K
didn't perform higher than the loan
costed them so I'm going why are we
putting money to a plan that we don't
control that has a lot of variables and
a lot of expenses and isn't creating
cash flow in his government like all
those kind of things when we could have
a more guaranteed path to cash flow by
paying off a loan that is a guaranteed
cost right because someone's getting
paid a commission for setting up the
401K plan and it's hard even for good
people to see the right thing to do in
that situation because they're just
saying no you need to Max Fund this it
saves you tax I once had someone
interview me on a podcast that said hey
you should put your money in Ira with
the tax savings you go buy one of
Garrett's programs I was like that's not
actually true through because the
money's stuck in the plan not in their
pocket and I'm not one that's going to
promote that they fund those types of
things I want people to to invest in
themselves that's the biggest message
and I know that sounds cliche to a
little degree but let's get deeper about
that because even saying dollars follow
value so create more value someone in
survival probably wants to hit me in the
face when I say that like it's hard
sometimes to figure out what is value
but value is perspective and it's what
someone else's perspective is so we have
to understand what is it we can provide
that's valuable to others that we're
capable of doing cuz I know people that
preach the word passion all the time and
the problem is Passion alone can lead to
bitterness passion can lead you astray
or even make you broke it's kind of like
putting fuel in the wrong place without
a tank and then everything bursts into
flames and it crashes that happens if
people are in a hobby that they're
passionate about thinking it's a
business they're like but I was told
that if I'm just passionate I'll be rich
no passion is a part of the equation is
helpful to accelerate to be fueled to
deal with the minutia to deal with the
tough days because this whole path is
hard easy not easy hard people that are
living the easy hard path they just
sleep in eat what they want don't think
about their finances just shovel the
money off work hard come home go back
it's just they get into routines and
they're not addressing difficult things
in life which might lead to family
situations I mean there's a lot of
things when we're when we're living easy
the things get harder our health starts
to be problematic you know all that kind
of stuff hard easy says it takes courage
to confront your finances it takes
courage it takes effort to look over
these things and learn some of these
things to watch this right now but if
you do the hard work now life gets
easier so the set it and forget in a
401k is easy hard hard easy is to say
should I be paying off a loan should I
be investing in more skills for myself
because I could get paid more if I did
that should I be you know just setting
money aside so I have enough liquidity
to handle Financial surprises that are
lurking in the corner cuz we're all
inore for financial surprises in our
life we just don't know when or how
severe I believe 90% of them could be
alleviated or at least not derell people
with basic financial decisions like
number one pay yourself first every time
you take a paycheck put it into a
separate account a portion of that money
so you're building some liquidity
instead of automatically investing I
believe in automatically saving and
deliberately investing be mindful of
your Investments don't try to learn
every investment that's out there Andrew
Carnegie said put put all your eggs in
one basket and watch it like a hawk
someone that you know or know of or
studied BJ Palmer said put all your eggs
in one basket and ensure it well the
people that make the most money invest
in what they know and they don't gamble
with everything else we've collapse
those terms what people say is investing
in their world is a lot of times
gambling and here's how you know it's
gambling risk isn't in the
investment risk is in the investor so
you have to ask yourself what kind of
investor am I am I investing with
knowledge and if I'm not it's time to
invest in building that knowledge
instead of speculating instead of taking
risk instead of handing my money over
instead of just hoping that it's going
to work out one day and you don't have
to learn as much as you think you just
have to be really good at a few things
so I think this is like a a highlight
with the idea saying because again it's
it's it sounds subtle but it's truly a
revolution save automatically invest
intentionally yes yet prevailing wisdom
and structures as they're set up for
working people is sort of the opposite
or maybe they blend it and say we're
going to invest automatically and that's
my savings right and and you know that's
a mistake but when there's Calamity and
when there's chaos you watch that go
down people get dragged into scarcity oh
yeah I believe never invest in something
that creates a scarcity mindset because
your greatest asset isn't a stock not a
bond not not even a business not even a
piece of real estate it's you and if all
of a sudden you invest in other things
that derail you distract you their
distractions disguised as opportunities
and all of a sudden you start getting
frustrated or you're fearful that crowds
out creative and productive thinking
that scarcity destroys wealth that's why
no amount of luck or saving or no amount
of discipline or no return or no
financial advisor can save someone in
scarcity scarcity inevitably destroys
wealth it's the wrong Viewpoint right so
effort won't solve that it has to be a
shift and then when we get that shift
and we start thinking about okay what
can I do to solve problems what can I do
to serve what can I do to deliver value
what can I do to increase some Financial
saving intelligence how can if I don't
know where to invest why don't I just
stay in cash and you know some people
never have to invest in anything that
has risk or speculation the majority of
my money goes into something that I
personally call Cash Flow banking it's
been my never fail me strategy I've
invested and made mistakes in real
estate oil and gas IPOs I even had a
hard money lending fund none of that was
in alignment with my investor DNA my
investor DNA is my values it's my
competencies it's my drivers combined
for focus when I got Diversified I found
out was diversification not
diversification and I was prematurely
diversifying and usually when you add
the word premature to something not a
good thing right like premature babies
is what I'm talking about there right so
so all of a sudden we're taking money
that in something we know like our skill
set or our own business or something
like that and we go give it to someone
else and they give it to someone else
the further that goes along the line I
call that the value chain the further it
away is from the center the more
confusing money becomes and the more
risk we take and the higher the risk the
higher the chance of loss because risk
defined is chance of loss I believe in
taking lower risk and getting better
returns because of information because
of investor DNA because of a good solid
Financial team I mean the Rockefellers
got this the bannerbts had no clue I
mean they knew how to make money they
had more money than the US Treasury but
it was 50 some years after Cornelius
died that the first Vanderbilt died
broke and by the way cornelius's first
son actually took and grew that wealth
for nine years so they actually doubled
their their estate but then it destroyed
and then they went and bought real
estate they knew nothing about and
mansions and there were no buyers for it
you know if you've heard of the breakers
and and and their mansions in Manhattan
got torn down Rhode Island they have one
that's now like you know something you
go see like as a Museum tour and
Anderson Cooper is a Vanderbilt who
didn't even receive money as an heir
because they destroyed that wealth
because they didn't understand it takes
a team no one can be an expert in
everything we have to utilize people and
understand so it's customized and
tailored so we can make more informed
decisions but never give up control of
the final Choice utilize these people to
give you the options stay in the
driver's seat because if you do you'll
have three feelings peace of mind
because you know what you're doing
Financial Clarity so that you can move
forward powerfully and more confidence
so you can focus on other things that
are really important in driving value
and Building Wealth when people invest
in things they don't know it's a
distraction when they invest in things
that are risky and it doesn't work out
it derails them for a time it starts to
actually chip away at their legacy and
even worse sometimes it destroys their
faith in investing allog together so
they just say I'm never doing anything
again I'm just stuffing it under my bed
and for some people I guess that
actually becomes a better thing than
losing over and over again this
infuriates me to watch Financial
professionals say things like dollar
cost average like you're in it for the
long haul like don't worry the market
goes up the market goes down all those
kind of things that's crazy we would
never run a business like that if we're
a good business owner we would never say
we're putting money into marketing no
matter what happens we're not going to
measure that hopefully it works out you
just go bankrupt and that's the same
level of financial intelligence most
people have it's on the level of an an
economic toddler right we never mature
past that because in school we're not
giving a money manual you know it's like
we're taking money home and we just got
to navigate and figure that out on our
own and for some people it just feels
confusing it feels overwhelming they
feel like there's a lot of sharks
there's a lot of shyers they make
mistakes so they get more closely
guarded and they they just confused and
that leads to inaction that leads to
scarcity that destroys wealth it
destroys velocity value exchange and
here's the situation we face today all
that let's wrap that around retirement
where you might live for 30 years after
you're no longer in control over your
life so the term Financial intelligence
is literally what uh money revealed is
all about right because if you look at
the enormous effort spent over a
lifetime to generate money to make a
living if you will to plan for a future
which is retirement or whatever else you
think your future plan is can you
imagine that people go through the
education they need the vocation getting
into a job or owning a business they do
all this work to start generating money
but then the the sum total is they don't
do the extra 10% of effort to now figure
out okay maybe I need to get some
intelligence around this and that
everything goes to a point and the
wheels come off because you never
bothered to educate yourself right and
to think think through these things and
be and this is the thing and and I'm
guilty as charged on this and this was
the you know literally a financial
miracle in my life in meeting you is
that I am a thinker and I really think
through everything I take I take my
intellectual life is maybe one of the
most important categories of my life and
I I spent so much time thinking about
life in every Dimension but I delegated
this to the people who said I am am an
expert in these areas well it's out of
term we relegate it yeah and that's
actually exactly you to me I was being a
good executive and delegate it was a
relegation though right and the upshot
was as I sat with you the first time
when we met and you started to uh
communicate to me the premises around
money from which you operated because we
shared so many other aspects of
philosophy together what you did is you
took that and applied it to money and
went deep with it and and and with
enormous amount of passion
I said you know what I'm passionate
about what I do in in the world and the
businesses that I build and develop and
relegated this part just automatically
because oh there's a structure in place
in the world and I cannot believe the
Dogma that I embrace I'm embarrassed to
actually tell you I mean I embraced
Dogma around this and I felt like you
took blinders off of me and had me see
the light around this so money revealed
is is a a a byproduct of the realization
that if someone like me can be
hypnotized and be unaware or blinded to
reality here well then I'm not the only
one and quite frankly for many people it
became too late when they found out and
we're hoping to reach many people now
where it's not too late so they can have
a transformation in their life in this
very important category called your
financial life yeah when I was 18 making
a financial mistake investing 70 bucks a
month and 3 months later figuring out it
wasn't going to work out not only did it
have have no chance 0% no statistical
relevance of actually being a
multi-millionaire from it had a
98.7% chance of failing all together
based upon the fee structure and the
actual performance from previous years
so it was a huge Awakening so I lost
money but that wasn't the last of my
mistakes I just made the mistakes
quicker I met Financial people that tell
me I've been in the business for 40
years after asking three or four
questions I realized they've been in the
business for one year and they've done
the same thing for 40 times over they
never question it I admit I've lost
money in real estate oil and gas I've
made the mistakes the difference was I
asked what can I learn from these
mistakes what are the biggest lessons
and what could I do to help other people
not make the same mistakes and give them
tools and strategies and you know you've
referred me people that have been with
me six seven years it's the first
seven-year period of life where they
didn't lose money because we're
protecting the downside we're thinking
about risk management but all of this
said you know if there's 10% % of money
that people think okay I got to save 10%
where I'm going to find that money when
I lost money in the stock market for my
clients in the year 2000 fortunately I
got all but one of their money
completely out of the market by by May
of 2000 with help and guidance from a
great mentor Steven harup who was a
money manager now my professor while I'm
at school we get their money out they
avoid two more years two and a half more
years of downturn and we figure out a
lot during that time I asked a question
and it was mainly out of pain because I
remember going to a family reunion and I
remember just being treated differently
because I was all of a sudden losing
family's money right all my family was
became clients just out of hey this is
our our nephew this is our grandson this
you know and I and you could tell they
were they were uneasy about it but they
love me so I was like I've got to figure
out something better than looking them
in the eye and saying you're in for the
Long Haul hey the Market's on sale buy
more like well that sale kind of sucked
cuz they had already bought and they
couldn't trade it in for the new price
that's the thing that's so stupid about
the the markets on sale so I asked a
question that I don't even think you're
allowed to say out loud in the world of
Finance I said what is guaranteed
because almost everything they say
around guarantees is past performance
not an indicator of future results there
are no guarantees but by asking that
question it changed the game for me
first off I recognized the game was
rigged against people here's how it's
rigged against them if you're a
financial institution what do you want
from people their money how often as
often as possible how long do you want
to hold on to it for as long as possible
how much do you want to give them back
if they want to take a withdraw as
little as possible that's why people are
not being wealthy they're in the money
times rate times time I left out time
earlier money times rate times time just
set money aside take a bunch of risk and
wait for a long period of time this is
why 401ks are so effective automatically
being taken from your paycheck not just
your money the government's money that
they're getting a fee off of as the
financial adviser penalties if you want
to get to your money early and when you
finally get to so-called retirement
leave the nest egg there just take the
interest
you see that so when I said what's
guaranteed this was the Epiphany I was
like what's guaranteed is if we could
figure out inefficiencies in someone's
plan on insurance if they have duplicate
coverages and costs an improper
structure you introduced me to someone
years and years ago I sat down with them
in Chicago what I found out was keeping
the same insurance company we changed
some things just tweak their deductibles
coordinated a couple pieces increase
their umbrella policy and lowered their
limits on other things this was just
their car home and and uh liability
policies we saved them 250 bucks a year
not too bad paid for brunch at the Four
Seasons for us that day though but
here's what was great I got him $10
million more of liability coverage just
by having that intelligence right so
that was one area that's a guaranteed
savings 250 bucks what's a bigger one
investment fees a lot of managed funds
don't outperform the index funds so just
to say let's have accountability around
our management fees because we talked
about going from 10% to 9.15% and having
it be hundreds of thousands of dollars
of difference over 30 years that's a big
deal but here's two other areas where I
saw the biggest guarantees one was
interest most people overpay interest
because they don't know the four C's one
you got to have a good credit score get
above 780 if you get a good credit score
you can then renegotiate interest rates
get good collateral if you finance a car
instead of just using a credit card you
can go from 1.9% rather than 8 10 15
177% so we've got credit we've got
collateral that could improve it we've
got cash flow reporting just knowing how
to report to the bank and the fourth C
is the right connections someone you
referred to me once again they ended up
buying a building with 10% down rather
than 20% down that was more cash in
their hand rather than paying 6% they
got 4.125% it was the four C's that last
one being the connection so imagine if
you could have the exact same loans
restructured renegotiated and
identifying how to pay them off more
efficiently you could end up shaving off
a third of the interest you pay and
keeping that money rather than giving it
to an institution that's guaranteed but
the fourth eye is the big one the IRS I
know there's people watching this from
all over the world so I'm just using the
I to keep it eyes you know Insurance
Investments uh interest and now IRS but
in our estimation after you know meeting
with thousands of people we believe 93%
of business owners specifically are
overpaying tax and not by a little by a
lot we've had people overpay their taxes
over a million dollars a year we've had
people overpay their taxes by $951 a
year we've had people go back three
years and have the IRS cut them a check
by amending their returns but all this
pay yourself first doesn't mean you have
to cut back and sacrifice it means with
a little bit of insight and framework
you can reclaim cash that's rightfully
yours put it back into your pocket get
Wall Street out of your pocket get the
IRS out of your pocket you'll still pay
your fair share there's no evasion here
whatsoever it's just simply stop tipping
the government give them what's required
and keep the rest and when you do that
you can start automatically saving and
then when that starts building up and
you figure out your investor DNA and you
know what investments make sense for who
you are instead of always being invested
like we've always been taught I believe
in something different I read an article
called predatory investing don't love
the name of the title but predatory
investing talked about Ted Turner
sitting in massive amounts of cash and
then when the economy changed when times
were tight when people were just needing
a baell out he bought companies he
bought sports teams he bought land and
then he'd move back into cash and he
would just wait and you know what during
recessionary times are the biggest
opportunities to grow your wealth if you
have liquid money if you're ill liquid
recessions transfer wealth and I look
look I know when we turn on the news the
news says oh there's been billions of
dollars lost in retirement plans money
isn't lost no one's burning the money up
it's transferred this is a deception the
world feels like oh we lost everybody
else lost no no no you transferred your
money to someone who was in the know
because you paid the ignorance tax we're
here to make sure the ignorance tax goes
away as much as possible so that people
could have a better life they could
become economically independent not
waiting 30 years but I've disseminated
I've studied since 1998 I said what's
the simplest framework that is not only
predictable it's inevitable that if
someone follows it they can achieve
economic independence and how long would
that take I met a few insane people that
got there within a year you know I think
of of people that have done that because
they just work 20 extra hours a week
they lived off food storage they just
did What it Took but there's people that
are Frugal right now that can get
economically independent in 3 years
where most people wait till they're 65
or 30 years from now maybe like me it
took 7 years it was because I just think
luxuries are now Necessities you know
and I like the Finer Things even though
I grew up in this coal mining town so
part of that is just you begin by
reclaiming your cash you so you boost
your profits keep more of the dollars
you make then second you figure out what
that number is per month that you have
to get an income that comes in if you
don't show up to the job or to the
business so that could be investment
income that could be entrepreneurial
income that is because of a team but it
still means that you need to monitor it
and manage it but once you identify that
number then you reverse engineer and say
what's our plan to get there then the
third step is you actually convert your
lazy assets to accelerate investment
income so accelerating investment income
means don't let any asset just sit there
and accumulate turn it on like cash flow
Banks when they borrow your money
they're trying to create cash flow they
want you to pay monthly they don't ask
you to to pay 30 years from now they ask
you to pay monthly start thinking more
like that how can I create cash flow
because if I can create that cash flow I
can get economically independent faster
then the fourth thing is to scale
Revenue this is where investing in
yourself comes into into plan you need
to be an entrepreneur or an entrepreneur
and if you're willing to do that you can
grow wealth because you can produce more
and financial books miss that far too
often and then the fifth one was the
hardest one for me to figure out because
in my 20s if someone said oh you up in
the mountains do you ski I own a
business what are your hobbies business
what do you do for
fun business I mean it was the same
answer I just was going to outwork
everyone I remember telling my dad that
I'm like I'm going to work like no one
else will work so one day someday I
could live like no one else could live
and he goes son what about the memories
you miss out on along the way it's like
damn that's a good point dad right but
the fifth one Make It Count MH have a
scorecard that's not just financially
related finan is one of your your
scorecards but have a second scorecard
of what matters most in life what
engages you what helps you build the
life that you love what are the things
that you enjoy what maybe it's taking
trips maybe it's having Hobbies maybe
it's getting together with friends but
actually enjoying life because if you're
the greatest asset and you take care of
yourself you've got more to give I've
met full-time stay-at-home parents that
never leave their kids side they do
everything for them to the point of
exhaustion they stop doing things for
themselves and they think that that's
the right way of doing and look I'm not
saying what's right or wrong I'm just
saying that sometimes if you get worn
out quantity doesn't beat quality and if
you all of the sudden do something for
everyone else and never do anything for
yourself there's not enough gas in the
tank so make it count is about
relaxation Rejuvenation so that you can
come back creative productive and come
back solving those problems and you keep
going through these five levers I call
them levers because it's these five
things boost profits or keep more of
what you make strategically engineer
wealth which is find out that number and
reverse engineering to build cash flow
take your existing resources and make
them cash flow rather than just
accumulate because there's this huge
huge misnomer out there in the world
that Einstein said that compound
interest was the eighth wonder of the
world he said compound numbers in the
1920s Security National Life lied
through their marketing instead he said
compound interest through a misquote
which has had people hand their money
over to the institutions wait forever to
get measly you know tiny bit off their
retirement I don't want people to do
that I want them to Take Back Control of
their finances I want them to utilize
this methodology and they can go through
the four eyes to reclaim cash they could
learn that it's not just about cutting
back it's about efficiency and more
production they could even figure out
that all all expenses aren't created
equal there's some expenses are
destructive let's get rid of those
destructive expenses you know let's just
eliminate that instead pay cash for
lifestyle expenses F focus on protective
expenses the Rockefellers did that's why
they're sixth generation strong and they
keep growing their wealth for the Vander
belts didn't have protective expenses
the Rockefellers created a family office
meaning they had an office of financial
professionals managing just their family
that helped them perpetuate wealth the
bannerbts didn't have that it was loose
and that's where the point you brought
up having a financial team and not just
a financial team just having people that
are there to mentor to coach to support
not just sale not people that are just
getting paid a commission not people
that are just paying you know assets
under management getting a fee but if we
focus on the fourth type of expense it's
the game Cher it's the solution to this
a productive expense we learn to invest
in people we learn to invest in ideas
that we're part of that we have
contribution to this is an investment
for you right this is an investment of
time for me we cash in on relationship
Capital to do this we spent a lot of
money in mental Capital to even share
these types of things we're being a
product of the very product that we're
talking about so people are drinking
through a fire hose right now obviously
ton coming at them especially what does
it do it opens your eyes said oh my God
there's so much here to think about so
much here to consider and I've been kind
of living in a a blind habit you know as
compared to saying there's a whole world
here worth exploring and the psychology
can be oh my God I feel overwhelmed or
oh my God this is amazing that I I have
all this new world to explore that could
be a really interesting world to explore
and certainly I'm the beneficiary of
that exploration right so now at some up
a bit and say what is the Garrick
Gunderson vision for the future how do
you how do you want to see the world as
a result of your efforts well I see the
world where people live their sole
purpose which is the best of who they
are it's really their abilities and it's
their passions and their values combined
for the highest context of living where
money is not their primary reason or
excuse where they can actually have
generational wealth that isn't just
money that passes On to the Next
Generation it's ideas it's contribution
it's those values it's the sign posts
and philosophies that were so helpful
and the lessons that they learned along
the way that can help people to go
further and live the life that they want
without being born into Financial
bondage again without creating entitled
kids so to me this is a chance for
people to change their fam's financial
future and overall their family's
Destiny I think with a business I want
it to be an ongoing concern that when
I'm gone it still exists it still cont
contributes to the world but I look at
the Gunderson family the same way when
I'm gone I don't want the Gunderson
family to be something that I had no
impact or influence over or contribution
I want people to figure out their own
path in my family but I want to have
symbols I want to have rituals I want to
have Traditions I want to have
philosophies I have a 52-page philosophy
that goes into my estate plan that says
whether there's money left in this plan
or not this is a book I want my great
great great grandkids to read to say how
did we navigate life knowing that
there's certain things that are going to
adopt and change but there's certain
timeless principles that we could share
that we spent millions of dollars
painstakingly figuring out from either
mistakes or masterminds or great
conversations and it's everything from
who we spent like here's I'll just give
one simple example from that one of the
biggest ways I've lost wealth over time
was not being more selective with
relationships so inside of my trust
inside of what's so called our statement
of purpose I put hey we suggest that you
create two categories for people friends
and friendly
we don't think that you need to have
massive blowups or or push your values
onto someone else or tell them why
they're wrong and spend all this energy
and getting involved in that drama just
be friendly with those people don't
share your vision listen to them don't
commit to anything you're not truly
wanting to do so just say no to their
invites and stop inviting them and then
take that extra time and invest it into
friends when I first met you I knew we
would be friends I knew so much that
when you said oh I've got this thing
coming up I know it's a week and a half
from today you'd never be be able to fly
out and make it I made it because I saw
that because I didn't have to spend time
with all the drama people or all the
people that that don't want to see me
succeed or hate my vision or judge me in
a negative way I wanted people I could
celebrate with I want people that when
they call me on the phone I want to
answer that call rather than
begrudgingly start draining my energy
and it's simple things like that that I
want to share with my family because the
two worst relationships I let in my life
they were more damaging than the 100
productive relationships in my life
during two major events and you know
what I learned lessons that I wanted to
teach my family like just because
someone does a favor for for you once
doesn't mean that you are enslaved to
them for the rest of your life and they
can abuse you just because someone says
that you're out of Integrity if
integrity was broken because they broke
the agreement you don't have to hold up
your end of the bargain anymore they've
already like things like that that I
want to contribute that I think will
impact their wealth but most importantly
I think could save them some of the time
now what I do want for them too is a
little bit of struggle M what I do want
for them is making mistakes but I want
them to make it when there's less at
stake and with someone to support them
and help pick them up so they could
learn a lesson in a more efficient
manner and to me if I can help people
discover that money isn't as complicated
as they think I could simplify it to the
point where they're only focused on
things that matter to them and they're
not spending time on options trading if
that's not their thing or tax leans if
they don't understand that where they
could dial it in so that they could
actually have more memories along the
way and that they could enjoy life and
live and express because I think all the
problems we're facing right now we have
the solutions within people's sole
purpose but money is clouding them from
living that because if your money ain't
right it's hard to join that fight you
know if you're not in a good place there
you can't think productively and one of
my my friends and yours Chris XO said it
really well once he said you know what
money used to be my master but you
really help me master my money and money
is a byproduct of value and that value
is a place where we store kind of our
energy and I want people to be able to
be productive an abundant rather than
scarce and destructive well that was a
phenomenal summary and uh I really uh do
mean it when I say I appreciate you
taking time to share this uh because I
think that this is a as much as much as
people look at um you know money being
sort of this uh material thing and this
material Pursuit uh everything you just
described is a spiritual context of what
it means to be a human being on planet
Earth to create values to share those
values with others and to have reverence
and respect for the fruits of those
labors so that um everything you care
about can be the beneficiary of that so
thanks so much Garrett for spending time
with us here thanks
[Music]
P now I've got a real treat for you I
interviewed Ray Blanco and Ry has a huge
following because of his ability to
research and come up with stock picks
especially in the biotech and crypto
areas so this is a stimulating interview
this guy's got unique intelligence and
perspectives that I learned a ton from
things I've never heard before so you
want to really get rid of all
distractions focus and dial into this
interview with Ray Blanco Ray I've been
looking forward to having this
conversation there's a lot of people
saying really nice and great inspiring
things about you so I'm looking forward
to uh interacting and finding out more
about what you're doing great it's great
to be here so uh tell us your background
uh kind of where you came from and how
you ended up being the editor for seven
figure publishing that you are today
sure you know even as a kid I was kind
of a geeky kid I guess you might say uh
big sci-fi buff uh I grew up in a world
uh you know where Star Trek represented
the future you know uh Humanities made
all these amazing discoveries uh remade
economy is going out to the
stars um there's a you know no scarcity
or want among the human species later on
I went into computer science and you
know I worked uh in both the public and
private sector um got to know a little
bit about the ins and outs of those
things uh you know how Wall Street works
on the technological level and you know
I started uh looking at the stock market
uh um you know technology stocks uh as a
cancer survivor I was always interested
in uh emerging biotechnologies and
pharmaceutical discoveries and things
like that I mean if not for discoveries
of the past I would not be here today so
um you know these you mind give us a
little bit more about that what was uh
what was your situation I was very young
I mean I had a rough time I think my my
mother really had it rough um I was
about 19 20 years old uh I was diagnosed
with Hodgkins lymphoma um not sure sure
why I got at such a young age although
it does tend to be one of the more
prevalent cancers in young males but you
know I went through surgery and I went
through uh radiation and uh you know
knock on wood it's been almost 25 years
now I think yeah and that got you
interested in in investigating and
understand uh kind of Biotech a little
bit more yeah yeah so interesting how
sometimes personal life experiences can
lead you on a career path there yeah
absolutely give you a purpose yeah so
you had a technology background and and
had an interest in this obviously what
was the path that got you into editing
these newsletters and getting into the
work you're doing today well it's like
anything else you know you meet people
along the way in life and you know you
make a favorable impression on a person
sometimes opportunity comes from that
and uh you know I ended up working with
a person who was a very good friend of
mine um he uh thought I could help him
with analyzing technology and you know
biotech stocks and things of that nature
uh help him with that process so you
know I did that for a while and ended up
graduating towards uh you know uh
writing about things myself under my own
name MH and well it's it's been a few
years now and it's been a great
experience so what are your activities
today what are you mostly doing so I'm
mostly involved in uh biotechnology uh
Tech uh the last few years we've been
we've been talking a lot about
investment opportunities in in the
Cannabis space which you know is
emerging as a global thing now you know
we're just in a time of incredible
change um just amazing things are
happening there's so much promised for
the future and you know what I help my
readers with is finding those
opportunities in a way that they can act
and and benefit and it's a two-way
street so in you know in investors
enable these new technologies these
world changing Technologies so and at
the same time they can profit from it so
you get to do well by doing good and you
know it's a beautiful thing and that's
an interesting question because
basically you you have a passion for
this world and you're seeing it having
some sort of a a beneficial effect on
humanity and creating this brighter
future absolutely and uh and at the same
time by investing in it people can can
benefit not only from the technology as
it emerges but also from the uh the
return on their investment they can make
on it right and you
know our thesis has been from the
beginning if you invest in a a basket of
some of the companies Investments
participating in uh you know the some of
the biggest Trends in technology or some
of the most promising technologies that
you're going to have Market beating
performance and what do you mean by a
basket uh well you want to spread your
bets around because not every good idea
works M uh or you know it's a good idea
but there there's competition that
emerges um in biotechnology not every
plausible theory of a how to heal a
disease um survives you know the cold
hard truth of reality in clinical trials
a lot of drugs never make it um so
there's stuff like that but if if if you
spread your bets around a bit the
winners will by far Eclipse your losers
and you're going end up end up ahead of
the game and you know that's what we've
seen for many years now and so this is a
part cuz I want to dig into some of the
things you're you know you you you are
betting on or think people should bet on
right now but the strategy is basically
take almost like a maybe a sector or sub
sector and saying hey there's three or
four or five or seven players in it and
really kind of spread bets around all of
them as compared to picking one right
can you give like an example of that uh
you know that that might be current sure
so biotechnology is a good example you
don't want to put all all your money in
one early Stage Company working on
cancer Alzheimer's disease you know you
want to look at and you got to get them
at the right time too you want to look
at uh a number of them and invest a
number of them maybe half of them might
not result in what you wanted but the
other ones especially if they're at the
proper stage of development you know
they're not a huge uh pharmaceutical
company uh they're a small cap and
they're they're still not on the market
with any products maybe half of them
will make it mhm their late stage phase
three and they'll have good results and
you know you'll end up you know triple
quadruple digit gains on on those kinds
of companies and the ones that were
failures you know you're offset there
right and uh and we talking about the
late stage talking about where they are
in FDA as far as the trials andal trial
process and and so you're kind of
tracking this whole process as it moves
along right now this is interesting uh
because if you look at the whole area of
SEL therapy and stem cells and and other
types of cell therapies uh it's kind of
the Wild Wild West right now so have you
been Have You Been analyzing this and
and have you been you giving some
opinions on this yeah so there's a lot
of stuff that gets touted that in my
opinion after following the space for
many years um it's probably never going
to yield any benefit but that doesn't
preclude stem cells stem cell therapies
themselves from you know having a lot of
therapeutic promise so you know there's
companies out there that do have um
platforms that show a lot of Promise
we've already seen some cell-based
therapies they're not stem cells but you
know 20 in 2017 the FDA approved two
cell-based therapies for treating cancer
um they're some of the first that we've
ever had we've got um you know emerging
uh cell therapies to you know for
regenerative medicine to rebuild tissues
that are damaged by disease or aging or
things of that nature so you know
there's a lot of uh of Promise in that
area it's been a long time coming but I
think it's finally starting to mature
that we're starting to get some results
in in terms of these therapies getting
into the market well what's interesting
is a lot of these therapies are in the
market um and there's companies that are
blossoming and growing out of it uh and
they're being applied every single day
but they there's not necessarily you
know FDA clearance for doing it uh how
do you think this is all going to shake
out well
the US has been difficult uh for these
kinds of therapies the FDA wants
something that you can replicate very
deterministically the problem with cell
therapies
um there's there's a lot of variance
from person to person everybody's genome
is different how how you know if you
give somebody stem cells for rebuilding
their cardiovascular system you know how
those cells multiply divide and do their
thing is very variable so we need
different metrics um the way we've you
know the FDA has
analyzed um new Therapies in the past
it's kind of a one size fits all sort of
a Model T Ford medicine approach we have
large numbers of people but um you know
as we've learned more about the human
genome and epigenetics and you know
we're all you know we're all snowflakes
in a way right right um we need to be
able to have a regulatory framework that
um can
can allow these more tailored sort of
therapies to emerge you know but the US
isn't the whole world there's other
parts of the world that have their own
regulatory Frameworks Japan has been a
lot more flexible in this now you know
the FDA is moving in the right direction
under um its new director Scott gly it's
been doing that under his predecessors
as well um we're seeing an FDA that's
working a lot more with uh developers
with these kinds of new therapies and uh
making it easier for them to bring them
to Market you know uh make a lot of
money but also help people in need so
right now have you been recommending
certain uh stocks uh or certain
companies saying hey we think they're on
the right path yes relative so can you
talk about those or what you've been
writing about oh well there's one
company I like a lot it's uh based out
of uh based in Alam California biot time
uh the man that founded the company um
he basically you know Dr Michael West
you could say he's the father
regenerative medicine he wrote the book
on stem cells he spent many years he's
accumulated a lot of intellectual
property he's figured out one of the
difficulties of stem cells is how do you
manufacture them MH and with high
quality consistency the cell the cell
culture that you're going to give this
person is precise you know those cells
are going to differentiate into the
right types of adult cells and that into
the wrong type that's a big deal so he's
built this whole cell manufacturing
platform uh he spent out the technology
out of biotime uh you know we just had
an IPO a few months ago U using biot
times technology the name of the company
is Ajax Therapeutics um Dr Wes is
heading that company now along with
world famous anti-aging researcher
Aubrey de gry uh he's he's got a big
role there and um they've made some
discoveries um they ran a
using basically supercomputers they ran
an analysis of all the changes in the in
in in a genome as it passes through the
embryonic through to the fetal stage
everything that changes and they found
this one
switch uh which is pretty amazing um
it's just mind-blowing so as you know
some forms of some animals like a lizard
loses his tail he can grow it back right
a crab can lose his claw he can grow it
back um certain lower forms of life have
just high power of regeneration and if
you go even lower you know a flat worm a
plaria flat worm you can cut it up into
50 pieces and you're going to end up
with you know 50 flat worms they all
grow into back into full grown worm so
what is this mechanism that they have
right that we don't because you know you
lose a limb that's it for life you cut
your spinal cord in an accident and
you're paralyzed for life so they've
identified the uh molecular switch so to
speak that gets flipped because when
we're when we humans are at the
embryonic stage of development we do
have this infinite regenerative power an
embryo can lose a limb and it can regrow
it whereas once you get to the fetal
stage we don't regenerate anymore we
heal mhm so you get injured you heal but
it's not you know you get a scar it's
never quite the same again so they're
developing um drugs that flip to switch
on mhm in different disease States so
imagine you have uh your heart is
Damaged from a heart attack and it you
can flip that switch and um the heart
will heal again it'll be like a new
heart again things like that um you know
they're working on talking about
cell-based therapies they're working on
ground adapost tissue cell lines you
write from bio time's original tissue
cells so this is not a very old
Discovery a few years ago they found out
that you have this um so everybody's got
white adapost tissue right that's the
fat we all know about and maybe not love
so much right um Brown adapost tissue is
actually found here in in the upper part
of your back behind your shoulder blades
and when you're very young you have a
lot of it m and it secretes certain
certain substances into the body that
regulate your metabolism uh the reason
they're brown is they have a lot of
mitochondria which are the power plants
of cells MH and they burn a lot of
calories you know babies you know
they're small but they they regulate
their body temperature pretty well uh
for their size is because they can turn
on that cellular furnace and generate a
lot of heat right uh however as you age
you start to lose these cells mhm uh and
you know the older people get to more
met metabolic problems they have like
diabetes and we're finding out a bunch
of other things are tied in to uh
metabolism uh all kinds of disease so
you know people with um diabetes or
obesity you know this could be a Cell
Therapy that would help them you know
restore a healthy youthful metabolism so
are are these companies or this company
in particular are they going through FDA
trials or are they offering in the
market saying hey we already so they do
have some stuff uh Ajax is is getting
there they're working on on on getting
uh an investigational new drug into the
clinic uh through the FDA so this is
really Prett pretty early stage stuff
it's kind of Swing for the fences
moonshot type of stuff right uh but it's
a kind of thing where you know it if you
want to have uh access to some of these
revolutionary technologies have them as
part of a long-term uh strategy you know
this is the kind of stuff that you want
to invest in yeah it's that's say is
that basically uh you you think it's a
good idea to have a basket of uh Cell
Therapy companies at varying stages put
some spread some money around there
because it's going somewhere yes that's
interesting and you know I guess the
different aspects that you have the
manufacturing side you said you know
who's creating the C cells and
distributing them and then I guess you
have the clinical application side you
know who's delivering them to to actual
patients are you a Believer uh in both
sides of this from an investment
perspective yeah both sides are going to
be valuable um you know the manufact
there's there's going to be money made
on both ends of it uh you can't have one
without the other why have the cells if
you don't have anything to use them for
right and you know you can't have the
application without the cells so you
need both sides of it and both of them
are important you know and there's other
stuff going on you this all involves
Gene editing as well uh and we're seeing
some of the first Gene therapies hit the
market um so from a biotech standpoint
Gene editing is another thing that you
think think it's holding a lot of
promise you know earlier this month we
had some very tany early evidence of
invivo Gene editing possibly having
Curative properties in humans so the
company's name is Sango biosciences and
they've got a gene editing platform
everybody talks about crisper right
everybody knows about crisper and
incidentally you not everybody you know
might know crisper but if you're
following if you're following this stuff
you understand Chris so it's it's a
platform where you can go in and go into
the DNA of a cell and make changes right
you know it's basically a code base a
database right uh the DNA molecule holds
holds a bunch of code
and it's a code of life um you know but
some people are born
with with some garbled data and they'll
have you know various inherited diseases
that they've either inherited from their
parents they just got an
unlucky Gene match between mom and dad
or you know there was a mutation very
early on during their development uh and
they they now have this issue mhm um and
most of these you know the ones that we
can treat it's lifetime treatment some
of them involve uh that you don't
produce an adequate enzyme MH and you
can't break something down in your cells
and it builds up there's many diseases
like this right um you know others might
involve you know muscular distrophy the
disten gene which is incidentally the
largest Gene in in in our cells uh is
got some bad data in it and you don't
produce the the the disten protein and
you get muscle wasting over time and you
know you don't live very long in the
more severe forms of muscular distrophy
but what if you could go in with these
folks and put in a working gene or edit
the bad Gene mhm you know and that's so
basically what crisper does is Gene
editing yeah gen editing Sango has a
different technology called zinc finger
uh nucleas U but you know it's it has
the advantage you can go in and with
great accuracy edit a gene or insert a
gene MH the recent data that they
presented was for a disease called MPS
and mps2 where they don't produce an
enzyme needed to uh break down a
glycoprotein and so this junk builds up
in your cells over time produces really
severe
effects and greatly shorten lifespan so
at what point when you're seeing
Technologies like this which are
basically you know the research it's
getting published you know they're
trying to move it on a track uh to get
it out you know for commercial use at
what point do you think people should be
saying uh it's a good time to invest in
it you know there's different ways to
invest I mean you can invest early and
and write it out for a long time or you
can uh which is a is a very viable
Strate stry um another way to you could
also trade right which is not quite the
same thing as investing you know a
company's got a major Catalyst coming up
um it could be you know a real big
binary event it could be clinical data
it could be an FDA decision and you know
you can do an analysis of what they've
got going on and decide oh this is this
is a good one to go long on MH um you
know in 6 months it could be could be
doing pretty well so you're placing a a
bet before event yes and hoping that
it's uh it comes out in your favor comes
out in your favor now do you when you do
something like that do you hedge it
somehow or do you basically just say
okay I'm pushing these chips onto this
bet you can yeah and there's there's you
know strategies to do so generally we
don't do that in our
services um although that's something
that we may be considering in the future
there's different option strategies that
you can use that you can hedge upside
and downside and things like that um
that are a bit more complex they're for
more sophisticated people so for the
people that are reading you know the you
know your research and information and
what you're putting out into the world
who are they typically uh are they uh
you know people that just have um you
know some discretionary income and they
have an interest in investing in the way
that you you know in the areas or the
sectors that you talk about uh like
who's your
audience my audience is is generally
people that have um worked very hard all
their lives they've made they've done
all the right
things um they've got a little bit
usually of discretionary income uh but
they want to use that to you know they
they want a little bit more money so
they can afford to send their kid to a
better school or they want a little bit
more for their own retirement or they
love the game right they want to be
involved in this it's exciting for them
and and they and they enjoy it um which
is perfectly understandable for me
and you know they just want to keep a
breast of what's going on in these areas
and and be able act on it in some way um
and benefit themselves so you know we
get those are typically the kind of
folks that that I write for no so let me
ask maybe the opposite question who
shouldn't be doing this like you who
shouldn't be like saying I'm reading
your stuff and I'm I I I want to like
you know put money into this like uh
when is that a bad idea well I mean you
shouldn't invest your nest egg or
anything that that you uh can't afford
to lose in in some of these ideas cuz
they're pretty speculative yeah and
they're high- risk which is why they can
be high return but they are high risk
but if you've got your you know your
financial basis set you got a little mad
money that you can play with in these
ideas mad money yeah like that yeah go
go for it yeah and and then so that
that's the that's the when it's time so
now one of the things you've been
writing about that's you know pretty big
is uh the whole cannabis thing right I
mean this is exploding on on the scene
yes and it's multifaceted right because
you've got uh the moral issues of people
saying you know this is you know this is
drugs it's it's you know the Mad Reaper
days you know from from that mentality
to the people saying my God this is a
miracle for so many people and and
what's how it's helping them in their
life and there's all derivatives from
you know medical marijuana to CBD oil
and how people are utilizing that and
hemp oil and you know stuff that is
legal to trade everywhere stuff and you
know you got fights between you know
what the Federal posture is on this
versus the individual states so it's
exciting but it's also sort of like wow
who can try to predict where this is
going to end up so how do you handle it
when you write about it it's such a
green field opport I mean literally
Green Field opportunity right now um
it's it's like ground
level um closest thing I could compare
it to is when the internet was just
starting out right and you had all these
new companies and people made fantastic
before the bubble popped right fantastic
gains on those things I think we're at
that stage we're still at that stage
right now um there's companies that are
not going to make it there's going to be
a lot of them a lot of pets.com out
there and there's some they're going to
be the next Amazon and Googles and stuff
like that of cannabis on the moral side
um you know I'm a big proponent
of I'm a very Liberty oriented person in
that sense um I mean alcohol and tobacco
are legal and they're not necessarily
good for you if you don't use them in if
if you don't use them in moderation
right I think cannbis is probably in the
same camp it's not a despite all the
fear-mongering of the past decades it's
not a truly dangerous dangerous drug I
mean we know this we've known it for a
long time uh I think it's been kind of a
travesty we've put so many people in
prison that were otherwise law-abiding
citizens right you know uh they're not
engaged in any kind of violence or
anything like that um really wrecked a
lot of lives we spent billions of
dollars fighting the market and you know
In the End Market always wins people
want something they're going to get it
one way or another and that's that's an
interesting thing as you're saying is
the market wins because exactly there's
always a market for it legal or illegal
and eventually the market won out on
this one and or and it's unfolding right
now that the market continues to win out
so what I think is we've had here in the
United States is for many many years
um a very
dedicated relatively small group of
people that have been pushing and
pushing and pushing the issue um and
they have gradually changed the opinion
of the majority it started with medical
uh there's been so many Amazing Stories
on the medical side just life-changing
stories and it's you know it's just a
profound stupidity we've been sitting on
this for so many years and who knows the
stuff we'd have right now if we had
allowed at least medical research more
medical research so I think on the
medical side is where people said how
can we not let others have access to
this if it helps them it's not Humane
right uh but that you know it's so
that's the gateway drug to the
recreational side right they always
called marijuana the gateway drug to the
hard stuff although there's there's
evidence now that it's the exit drug
from the the hard stuff there's some
evidence of that um so you know people
have become more relaxed uh I mean we've
actually got majority of the country now
thinks that recreational should be okay
mhm what we've seen in the United States
for quite a few election Cycles now is
we see ballot initiatives and state
after state after State you know my own
state Florida in 2016 finally allowed
medical um you know I've seen it help
family members with uh different
autoimmune conditions and things like
that uh so you know we've seen States
going medical then we have a smaller
number of states that are allowing adult
use or recreational use there's a lot of
problems with implementation right now
you know especially the at the federal
level
MH where it's still a um a
highly restricted substance it's it's
it's such a bizarre situation so you've
got the national Institutes of Health
holds a patent on cannaboids because of
their medical neuroprotective properties
the NIH can have its own patents yeah
well they do and then they license those
patents a lot of good stuff comes out of
out of the NIH wow but but isn't that
kind of strange because that means
they're in the bit when they license it
are they making a profit from the
license or how does that work they can I
mean it's I don't know the whole story
of how the NIH uh licenses out um some
of its the stuff it discovers a lot of
the stuff it discovers is really really
really early stage so if they license it
to a to a pharmaceutical company they
got to do the hard work so they
discovered this drug Target or this
mechanism they maybe even discovered a
molecule that does something very
interesting that might alter a disease
state so this is interesting because you
know if it's if it's tax dollars you
know that that funded the NIH and they
create patents that that should be
public property where anybody should be
able to use it I mean from a Libertarian
standpoint at least that's true but
who's going to spend $200 million
bringing this idea to Market well I get
it but now anybody should have should be
able to utilize the IP is is my point as
compared to them you know being able to
decide what company gets to use this and
what doesn't in a perfect world that
might be true but if you don't have
exclusivity it's very unlikely that
you're going to invest the money to take
it to Market to take it to Market and
take all the risk on because you know
from that from Discovery stage through
the market you know more than 90% of the
stuff here never makes it it's plausible
it looks good but it'll fail in in early
trials or in midstage or heaven forbid
even in a late stage after you've spent
five 10 years and you've put tens of
millions of dollars in so this is
interesting so from the investment
standpoint so now we've got you know
what we're looking at environmentally in
this uh and I'm talking about the
financial or investment uh environment
you've got literally a federal
government who's had this great
opposition to marijuana now but but yet
the federal government holds patents on
on uses it's like one hand and the other
not knowing what what they're doing
right oping independently so the DEA
says this is a highly
dangerous uh uh substance with no known
medical applications right and then you
got the NIH holds a patent on the
neuroprotective properties of cannaboids
right so it's it's just bizar yeah it's
bizarre so we can go with the people
who've done the science we can go with
the people who just have hysteria that
they've inherited and the thing is you
know government bu
bureaucracies after a while they become
self-serving right and their biggest job
is to continue to exist and to grow yeah
and for you know the DEA to uh willingly
uh you know reschedule or remove
marijuana is listed up there with heroin
and cocaine crazy all this kind of stuff
so now I'm the investor I'm excited
about the prospects yet you you know we
we spent a few minutes here talking
about how crazy you know it's like crazy
land here you know as far as the the
regulatory side of this and and state
governments Federal governments federal
federal government contradiction and all
that kind of stuff so now but I I'm EXC
let's say I'm excited about this I I've
got some discretionary money I want to I
want to put some money into this Place
some bets on this how do I sort this out
or when you're writing about this where
where are you guiding people well I mean
I'm taking the approach uh and we take
both the long and short-term approach in
different in different Publications um
the long-term approach I think is to
invest in the best quality cannabis
companies out there which have tended to
be Canadian and even that's not perfect
there's been some stuff that's gone on
um you know uh Canada's been a really
early Frontier they were early at the
national level with medical and you know
uh they were they've been early also
with the adult youth and you know the
implementation has been bumpy but
they've got the most mature well-
capitalized companies there uh you can
speculate on some of these itty bitty
ones uh and that's fine but on the
long-term side I think that's the best
way to go there's opportunities emerging
uh all over the world uh I don't
necessarily think Canada is going to be
the epicenter of cannabis production um
I mean they're not the epicenter of
banana production for a reason they
don't have the climate for it right
right although you can grow bananas in
Canada if you want to spend the money on
a greenhouse in climate control um so
there's going to be other parts of the
world that are going to to I think
eventually be the leaders have you
recommended any uh particular companies
or initiatives uh in the Cannabis world
for investment thus far well late last
year I visited um Columbia
and I'm a little bit familiar with
what's been going on over there so I was
in the meing area which is very famous
uh if you you know watch Naros on
Netflix and Pablo Escobar and all that
right uh so you know that place is
somewhat Infamous undeservedly so
because it's a beautiful city and it's a
beautiful area um so but that area and
also around bot the proper elevations
it's a uh Cut Flower Powerhouse so we
used to grow a lot of flowers North
America we don't grow quite as many as
we used to uh just because you know
climate is King M over there uh you're
in the tropics so you don't get a lot of
seasonal variation in sunlight M you
have um at the right altitude you have
the perfect temperature for
chrysanthemums a little bit higher you
have the perfect temperature for Roses
year
round and you know all you need is a
very simple open air uh clear plastic
Greenhouse
to keep the rain from hitting the the
plants and causing mold or mildew on on
the leaves and the flowers and you know
they've already got an established uh
labor base expert in working flowers and
is there but are they taking investment
in these particular they're going
they're flipping they're starting to
flip into the Cannabis my understanding
is it was an obscure law on the books
cannabis is not legal in Colombia
but it's only legal for medical but
there was no regulatory framework so
they worked and they created regulatory
framework and just like they took over
I'm not maybe not the majority of the
world's flower production but I think
pretty close to it I I think uh they're
going to be pretty big in cannabis
production able to do it a lot cheaper
than than in some other places and at
the end of the day as the industry
matures if you can be a lowcost high
quality producer MH better than others
then you're going to be you know the the
mass the the mass Market winner we've
got so you're talking about the farming
side right now right so then you got
farming you probably have uh you know
wholesale distribution and then you've
got uh the retail side of it you know
and I'm I'm probably in the recreational
space more than the medical space
speaking to this um so do you think uh
where do you think the best place is to
go invest is it on the farming
production side the wholesale retail all
the above the thing is a lot of the
really good companies even a lot of The
Not So Strong companies are pretty much
trying to be complete vertical mhm where
they have production where they
transform the product into oils or
tinctures and extracts right and then
their own um retail they want to be
complete vertically integrated yeah they
want to have the whole vertical so a lot
of them will have that some are are
specializing in just either production
or or just branding and Retail and stuff
like that yeah cuz I'm I'm seeing now
some there's some uh people buying for
you know brand development and brand
awareness and and that's starting to
emerge now like I'm hearing a lot of
commercials for Coca-Cola and they
exactly and that's going to happen
eventually and do you think that's a
good place to place a bet saying hey
these these people are starting to
develop a known brand and so they're you
want to spread the bets around yeah kind
of like like you know Bitcoin might be
to crypto in general it's like you know
you want to spread around you want spr
around it's really hard to say who's
ultimately going to be the Amazon of
this or the Coca-Cola um although that's
you know as as industry is mature they
always tend to consolidate into a few
big players and then you might have a
few bit players doing you know you've
got Budweiser and and Miller and all
this stuff and beer but then you got the
little micro breweries you know you've
got that it's like specialty coffee
versus Starbucks or something yeah yeah
but I think the most also a very
exciting thing is is the medical side um
believe it or not there's going to be a
big market and there is is a big market
for um cannabis derived Pharmaceuticals
M that will be covered by insurance will
be a very
pure proven product um there's there's a
lot of work there last year we saw the
the first ever FDA
approval uh of a directly cannabis
derived therapy um British company GW
far Pharmaceuticals mhm they they uh got
the FDA to approve epidex is the name of
the products it's for children with
certain rather rare forms of epilepsy MH
so you know they had clinical data
showing that they could cut seizures
down in half these kids are getting
everything we've already got and I have
to imagine that the adverse effects are
nil because it's it's it's derived from
you know plant and such a way as
compared to something that might be more
toxic well yeah it's not toxic I mean
the deadly dose of cannabis would is
incredibly incredibly High much higher
than the therapeutic dose so it's it's
inherently safe right so um you know
they developed this therapy for I mean
they've got other stuff going on at this
company I mean they've got some really
tantalizing early stage data they've got
another cannabis extract that um
showing and I hope they take it further
in Trials it can make a real difference
in brain cancer MH wow yeah so there's a
lot of stuff going on there so what is
it about your writing or you do why you
why are you so popular why why why is
your newsletter yeah why are they so
popular you and I know it might seem
like you don't want to self a grand eyes
but but I'm I'm literally you know like
saying there seems to be this sort of
like your I don't know if it's your
style your content a combination that
but people really love what you write
well objectively we do really well our
averages every year at the end of the
year I uh I calculate our average uh
gain and I mean we just do really well
uh so there's that and I love what I do
I mean this job is just amazing I get to
talk to amazing people every day um
learn new things it's there's just so
much cool stuff going on and you see so
many people uh just
dedicated uh you know dedicating their
lives
to you know healing disease or manying
new technologies and things like this
you know it really gives you hope in
humanity there's there's we're pretty
you know there's a lot of good stuff out
there a lot of good people so I'm
wondering like how you see this because
uh you know a lot of times when people
think about investment and or even
trading in the market and and doing
these types of things it's a it's almost
very mercenary in its in its feel it's
like you know I just want to go make
money but you seem to have this sort of
Hope For Humanity in the work that
you're doing it's not you know I mean
obviously yes you're you're talking
about hey we we do well we get we get
great returns you know we calculate our
Our advice and see what the impact is
for people who follow it and that that's
the the money side but there seems to be
a spiritual nature to this with with you
so tell me tell me how you experience it
yeah I mean I get to be immersed in and
document human
progress you know it's this you know
long story we've had we as a as a
species we you know we take two steps
forward we go one step back bad things
happen but as a general rule things have
just been getting better and better um
you
know compared to our grandparents and
great-grandparents lived as Society
becomes wealthier um there's things that
are not so great but I mean I think
we're more free to have empathy for each
other because we're not so scared about
our own personal survival that we're
more free to to reach our our individual
potential plus it's just as Fascination
finding out how the world works you know
you know human biology we've been
talking about that a bit today right
it's just such a fascinating intricate
piece if you look at it as a machine I
don't know if it's that's exactly right
but um it's just so cool I mean how did
this all this come about it's just
amazing and we're learning new stuff all
the time I mean the nice thing about
what I do is it's never boring M um and
I get to learn new stuff every day and I
get to share it with other people so
pretty lucky guy right here we've
certainly have had uh a lot of
conversations in this
uh documentary series around uh
cryptocurrency and blockchain and spent
a lot of time at overstock.com now
that's a pick that you had early on uh
that seemed to go very well with you
what what's your view on the whole
crypto blockchain thing so I am quite
skeptical on cryptocurrency uh I like
the idea of an alternative monetary
system that can't be manipulated by the
central
banks um so I like the idea I'm just
somewh skeptical about the
implementation now the foundational
technology of crypto you know is
blockchain uh this mysterious person
invented it back in I think it was 2009
when everything was melting down he
invented it to enable
cryptocurrency uh I think blockchain you
know and there's derivatives of that uh
is a a world changing idea because it's
decentralizing and it it makes trust
between two people that don't know each
other possible without an intermediary
MH so what I liked about Overstock was
um their involvement with uh medich
Ventures and all of the startups that
they were funding uh they were building
um an exchange t0 MH which was going to
be the uh the world's first SEC
compliant um
secure distributed you know
blockchainbased
equities and Securities Exchange right
and that was a really cool idea because
you know Patrick burn who is the guy
behind all this um you know he's been
pointing
out the rapaciousness and mercenary
nature of Wall Street and the things
that they do like naked Short Selling he
wanted to make this whole process
transparent and some of these practices
that are performed in Wall Street make
them impossible and level the playing
field between everybody so that's what
t0 is attemp to do but you know they're
doing other amazing things um you know
blockchain uh secured and enabled um
voting uh one idea that they have that
that they have that's very exciting that
they're working on is a global uh
property registry MH you know which here
in the United States we really don't
realize how good we've got it I can look
up uh any property anywhere in the
country and see the entire chain of
ownership going back
who knows how far right um and you know
if I own a property it's legally not
dubious at all it's very solid I can do
what I want with it with it within the
law but not true in a third world it's
not true in a lot of places I mean I've
looked at real estate overseas and it's
like how do I know this person selling
this really owns it right it seems that
the investment World SL banking world is
rigged and has been rigged for people of
privilege you know the Insiders you know
got the the right line knows the right
people can get the right input and
advice and working people guys like me
go to work every day who maybe even make
pretty good money or what have you and
maybe might have discretionary money to
invest just don't have the you know the
the Avenue uh or the you know the
connections if you will to be able to do
it and with you know wisely to be able
to have some sort of context for it so
is is there part of that the nature of
you know the David and goli you got
these Big M monsters out there who are
just profit profiting all the time and
we're frozen out that what you do and
and the type and other people like you
do is the the line that you know the
connection we can have to try to make
good investment yeah so the driving idea
there is uh we're a Marketplace of ideas
um we're a number of iders and experts
um all of us are are are employed in our
day-to-day work uh looking after our
families we don't all have the time to
be insiders or be experts so you know we
offer uh me and my colleagues uh and
they we all have different areas of
expertise uh what we offer is um that
expertise that does help level the
playing field uh you know many of my
colleagues have worked at hedge funds uh
have been money managers um things like
that and now they're offering their
services for you know regular folks um
so that they can uh take advantage and
you know actionable opportunities it's
not just uh for entertainment
entertainment value although some stuff
is very entertaining right but
actionable ideas that our readers can
use to achieve their goals and and to
better themselves yeah you feel like we
we got access to that information and
and say Hey you know I I I you know I
like this field that you're talking
about in you know cannabis or biotech or
or you know even blockchain and you know
I can go in there and say I'm I'm going
to put some money into this particular
company after reading but I I suspect
that you know the way that you write
it's it's it's entertaining or
intellectually stimulating in and of
itself and then every once in a while
something resonates and you place a bet
right so uh it's it's really kind of
this I I think a great emerging service
that that you can get this out to to you
know the everyday people as compared to
just you know the people who live this
stuff every day and kind of it's
incestuous in their own world that they
kind of just support each other so it's
great and I I very much appreciate you
you know uh you sharing this and your
wisdom with me and what you do every day
of your life well it's it's been great
I've really enjoyed this conversation to
see the next episode in the money
revealed series check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there this is at a time where we have a
stock market at alltime highs behind the
curtain it's growing at 8% so here's the
question where'd the money go